QUITE LIKE THIS.
TRACE GALLAGHER, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
KEEP IN MIND, NORTH KOREA AND
SOUTH KOREA WILL HAVE A SOMEWHAT
WEAK.
THEY WILL TALK ABOUT ENDING THE
KOREAN WAR.
NOW TO TONIGHT'S OTHER BIG
STORY.
THE JAMES COMEY MEMO.
NOW WE NOW KNOW WHAT IS A MUST
MEMOS THAT MIGHT JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT'S WATCHDOG ALSO KNOW
WHAT IS THE MOST MEMOS AND
THEY WANT TO INVESTIGATE WHETHER
TWO OF THEM HAVE LEAKED
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION ON THE
INSIDE OF THEM WHEN HE GAVE SOME
OF THOSE MEMOS TO HIS GOOD BUDDY
AT COLUMBIA JUST UPTOWN HERE,
WHO WAS AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
FOX NEWS CHIEF INTELLIGENCE
CORRESPONDENT CATHERINE HERRIDGE
IS TRYING TO STAY UP WITH US.
MAN, THIS BOOK TOUR IS GETTING
QUITE INTERESTING.
ISN'T IT?
>> IT IS, BRIAN.
FOX NEWS CONFIRMS THAT COMEY IS
UNDER INVESTIGATION BY THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S INTERNAL
WATCHDOGS.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL FOR
LEAKING THE MEMOS, WHETHER HE
MISHANDLED CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION AS WELL AS HIS
COMMUNICATIONS OUTSIDE THE FBI
INCLUDING REPORTERS.
THE MEMOS SHOW THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT AND COMEY
WAS DIFFICULT ON THE VERY
BEGINNING.
AFTER COMEY BRIEFED MR. TRUMP
ABOUT DOSSIERS UNVERIFIED
CLAIMS, JUST THREE WEEKS BEFORE
THE INAUGURATION.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS THAT HE
WANTED THE RUSSIA CLAIMS
INVESTIGATED.
COMEY SAID THAT IT WOULD BE GOOD
TO FIND OUT BUT HE HADN'T DONE
ANYTHING AT HOPED HE WOULD FIND
A WAY TO GET OUT, WE WANT
INVESTIGATING HIM.
THE PRESIDENT'S SAYING THAT HE
CROSSED THE LINE -- COMEY
REPLIED THAT HE WOULD ALWAYS GET
HONESTY FOR ME.
TRUMP PAUSED AND SAID, THAT'S
WHAT HE WANTS COME ON HIS
LOYALTY, I REPLIED AND SAID, HE
WILL GET THAT FOR ME.
THE 15 PAGES OF MEMOS, IT
CONTAINED CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, SECRET, HIGHLY
CONFIDENTIAL, WHICH SEEMS TO BE
AT ODDS WITH COMEY'S
CONGRESSIONAL TESTIMONY AFTER HE
WAS FIRED.
>> MY THINKING WAS THAT IF I
WRITE IT IN SUCH A WAY THAT I
DON'T INCLUDE ANYTHING THAT
WOULD TRIGGER A CLASSIFICATION,
THAT WILL MAKE IT EASIER FOR US
TO DISCUSS WITHIN THE FBI AND
THE GOVERNMENT, AND TO HOLD ONTO
IT IN A WAY THAT MAKES IT
ACCESSIBLE TO US.
>> BUT IN HIS VERY FIRST MEMO IN
JANUARY OF 2017, COMEY KNEW HIS
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE PRESIDENT
WERE SENSITIVE AND NOT PUBLIC
INFORMATION.
"I'M NOT SURE IF THE PROPER
CLASSIFICATION, SO HAVE CHOSEN
SECRET.
PLEASE LET ME KNOW IF IT SHOULD
BE HIGHER OR LOWER THAN THAT."
TONIGHT, WE HAVE A SERIOUS
INVESTIGATION BY THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND ANOTHER APPARENT
CONFLICT BETWEEN THE DOCUMENTS I
AND COMEY'S TESTIMONY, BRIAN.
>> Brian: YOU CAN'T SAY THIS
IS POLITICAL, PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
DOJ, THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
APPOINTED BY PRESIDENT OBAMA.
>> THAT THAT IS CORRECT.
>> Brian: GREAT JOB.
YOU MAKE IT SOUND SO SIMPLE BUT
YET WE KNOW IT IS VERY
COMPLICATED.
MEANWHILE, STRAIGHT AHEAD --
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND.
COMEY SPOKE ABOUT LEAKING THE
MEMOS DURING THE INTERVIEW WITH
GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS, THE
INTERVIEW THAT NEVER ENDED.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS TWEETED
INNUMERABLE TIMES CALLING YOU A
LEAGUER.
WHAT IS A RESPONSE TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> IT'S TRUE.
I TESTIFIED AT.
THAT IS SO PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT IT.
I GAVE THAT OUR CLASSIFIED MEMO
TO MY FRIEND AND ASK HIM TO GIVE
IT TO A REPORTER.
THAT IS ENTIRELY APPROPRIATE TO.
>> Brian: REALLY?
IN WHAT WORLD?
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"'S
EDITORIAL BOARD, ONE OF HER
LATEST, SHE TALKS ABOUT THE
QUESTIONS THAT SHE WANTS
JAMES COMEY TO ANSWER.
HIS REASONING IS BIZARRE.
HE SAID HE NEEDED TO GET THE
INFORMATION INTO THE PUBLIC
SPHERE.
WHAT IS IT, 1778?
>> HI, BRIAN.